what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 6 of the deep learning in Python
with tens flow and caris tutorial series
in this video we're going to be talking
about how do I use my model so a lot of
people have been asking ok great we
trained and tested our you know data set
or whatever but like ok I've got some
outside images how do I use these and
make predictions on these so that's what
we're gonna be talking about here we are
going to be using the following the
following script here that was our cats
vs. dogs data set basically and we got
84 percent validation accuracy 89
percent accuracy so maybe he's beginning
to overfit a little bit but that's okay
and it was saved as a 64 by 3 Convenant
now I guess I think I might even delete
this I just want to show you guys that
you don't actually actually need like
your model so a lot of times like with
tensorflow
in order to load a model you actually
have to define the model before you load
in the model because generally the model
itself is actually just some like weight
definitions so you have to have the
model there to like be populated and
such a simple thing but chaos and I
don't think testable has yet but chaos
you you can just load in a model period
you don't have to worry about defining
the model first so it's pretty pretty
nice and if this is your first time in
the deep learning you probably wouldn't
wouldn't respect that but anyways I'm
actually just gonna delete this so just
note that we saved the model 64 by 3 CNN
model ok so good day so I'm gonna go
ahead and restart and run all maybe yes
sir ok so now we're gonna go ahead and
do is begin working on this so what I've
done is somewhere oh it's right here
dude ok I've got some outside photos so
this is a photo of my dog with the cone
of shame he's got some staples in his
face cuz he's stupid and then I've also
got a cat here so these are two images
this is my dog and he's not on Google
Images as of yet and although once he's
the tutorials maybe is and then maybe at
some point he'll be in the cats versus
dogs dataset but right now I can be 100%
confident this was not in the data set
also this is a creature that hangs
around a house and because food gets put
down in such and such anyways this is
also an animal that is not in the data
set 100% so this is true true testing of
the data so what do we want to do well
we are going to import see me too and
then we're also going to import
tensorflow as TF then we're gonna grab
those same categories that we had before
so we had it was dog and cat so
basically a lot of this is the same kind
of pre-processing that we had to do
before and then some of it is like the
reverse of what we had to do before so
for example here categories well we did
this initially so we could take the
categories dog and cat and convert
string dog string cat to numbers and now
what we're going to do is is the
opposite is take the number and convert
it back to a string so we're gonna use
the same you know categories list that
we had before now we're going to define
prepare and prepare is just going to
take a file path as the parameter so
this will be the image that we feed in
so what do we have to do with this image
well we need one thing that's to resize
the other is we want to grayscale that
image same as what we did before and I
honestly forget I think in the videos
I've been I did 70 so the images were
resized to a 70 by 70 and I think in the
text-based version I had started with
like a 50 so yeah just make sure this is
the same number you used moving along
image we're gonna load in image if I
could type image or a equals cb2 Dhanam
read file path and then we want to read
it in a CV to dot all caps em read grey
scale so that converts it to grayscale
now we want to resize it so new array
and you could resize this like all in
one line
you can encase this and see v2 dot
resize it just makes it kind of super
long and hard to read CPT dot resize
what do we want to resize one resize
image array and what is the size don't
make that a list it's tuple what is the
size it's gonna be image size by image
size so that's our new array finally
we're going to go ahead and return that
and we're gonna return new array dot
reshape and we got to do that silly
reshape that we have to do with chaos
that one poops one day we won't have to
do any more and I'll be telling newbies
you should respect this back in Monday I
had to do all the reshaping and it was
super annoying okay so next good old guy
boys so now we nice need to load in the
model so TF chaos models load model and
again this was sixty four by three - CNN
model whatever you named it if you named
it something different loaded in and
again like I was saying this is really
nice before you had to define the whole
model then you load it in the model and
if anything was off it just just blew up
so this is nice so next once we've
loaded in the model we're ready to make
a prediction so we're gonna say
prediction is equal to model not predict
and then in here always always always
you pass a list don't forget it predict
always predicts against a list even if
you just want to predict one thing and a
lot of times you are just going to be
predicting one thing and you're gonna
forget that list and you're gonna like
what the heck is going on so just
remember that prepare and then we're
gonna pass file path I've got dog and
cat jpg so we're gonna do dog jpg first
and then first let's go ahead and print
prediction ah tensorflow cures it okay
Cara's strike in do you took forever
okay so the prediction here is a list of
a list another seemingly useful thing a
useful change and again this one I
actually don't know if it's changed in
tensorflow as well so for the longest
time if you wanted to do categorical
classifications you would need to use
what was called a one hot array and now
we can actually make these like sparse
you know scalar classifications where
it's just one value and that's really
cool because now I don't have to you
know you used to have to get the return
and then do an NP org max or whatever
whereas nowadays that's not necessary
this just this does it for you which is
pretty nifty the only thing I don't like
about this is I can't apply a weight to
it after the fact so maybe more on that
later I'm not gonna get too deep into
that but yeah you might not always want
to do it this way anyway okay so we got
our prediction now okay how long did
that take right that that kind of that
took a you know a few milliseconds right
one thing to note is if you're loading
in your model every single freaking time
that's gonna take a while but if you
just want to do the prediction part
that's like it should be like nearly
instant it should be very very fast and
also keep in mind you can you can batch
your predictions as well so there is
like a thing called like tensorflow
serving where you can I guess the idea
is to for more of a production type
server but I'm gonna be honest with you
never used it this is what I use I just
straight up use model dot predict it's
very fast there's I can't imagine why
you would need it much faster unless
you're like Facebook or something or
Netflix and you're trying to make
recommendations to like millions of
people almost at the same time otherwise
I really don't know I don't know why you
would need anything faster and in fact a
lot of times this can actually be like
you want to train on a GPU because
you're trying to constantly be training
batches of like 32 128 500 or more right
so so you need a GPU but in general if
you want to actually you know send a
model to production a lot of times you
can actually just run that model very
comfortably on a CPU anyway enough that
let's make this a little more pretty so
prediction 0 0 that's just the number we
could convert that to an integer make it
even more pretty and then finally we can
give it its most beautiful appearance by
saying
categories and make that the index in
the categories boom now we've got a
string look at us now we're gonna take
this let me fix this little space come
over here paste
let's change cats and boom we've got our
prediction of a cat again totally
out-of-sample was not used for training
100% confident in that so pretty good so
if you've got some pictures of dogs and
cats go ahead and try them out obviously
there will be some degree of error it
was only about like a little over 80%
accurate but on average it should be 80%
accurate so it's questionable like is it
80% accurate and it does it like get dog
and cat equally wrong 20% of the time or
or is it actually wrong about let's say
cats you know half of the air let's say
it could be wrong about cats or it could
be right about cats 60% of the time and
right about dogs a hundred percent of
the time and still give you that average
eighty right hopefully that quick maths
is correct someone let me know below if
I screwed up but anyways
obviously that balance could be way off
right it could be this model could be
really really good at predicting dogs
and kind of an at cats or something like
that so you want to check that stuff
before actually using it in production
but yeah okay so I think that's all for
now a quick shout out and thanks to the
recent sponsors actually they're called
members now so thank you to Michael Nick
Rodrigo and papasan E for your support I
really really appreciate that you guys
are awesome so anyway that is all for
now if you've got questions comments
discerns whatever feel free to leave
them below if you've got anything more
you want me to talk about or build upon
on this let me know if I left anything
out let me know the next tutorial I
think is gonna be recurrent Nets I'm
still trying to sign on like what kind
of data set to use you know recurrent
net is it's it's really for sequential
types of data things like natural
language or like time series data and
stuff like that but natural language is
very very challenging I don't really
think I want to do that as a basics
tutorial in
and a lot of time series data needs to
be quite complex before we can actually
get anything from it so I'm not really
sure what I want to do if you have a
suggestion for a data set that you think
would be a simple one to use with a
recurrent net let me know otherwise I
might wind up having to do like eminence
or something like that because it's
successful or we could do a time series
with like stocks or something like that
although a lot of times when I do stocks
people are quick to tell me I don't like
stocks okay it's just an example
everybody okay so let me know in the
comments what you want to see a
recurrent net being used for and keep in
mind has to be basic enough that
hopefully I can get it done in one video
most of the stuff I can think of that I
would use recurrent Nets for or it's
like a it's a meaning series of its own
so anyways let me know below otherwise I
will see you guys in another video